succession
so we're caught up yeah we're caught up
so yeah you're watching the show
everybody dies
so a quick warning you guys if Kendall
Ruckus
[Laughter]
skip forward five to ten minutes yeah
it just goes right dude
yeah we should leave
we should leave five minutes of Blank
Space pure silence and then right at
five minutes Logan dies
but did that catch you off guard it did
and I think I think what made it genius
and what the stain on the show is now
is like that's how death feels
when someone dies
there's like yes it's just over yes
there's no closure you don't get to like
reel it back in yeah you're like oh what
yeah done I thought that was I thought
that was a like a beautiful part about
it was just how like realistic the
situation was but I also think
it was genius how they that's how it
started that's the whole that's the
point of the show is figuring out who's
gonna take over when he dies that's
always been the thing that's gonna
happen yeah but throughout the last
three seasons they've done such a great
job at like
building it up towards this other thing
that's happening that when it did
finally happen you're like oh what the
[__] yeah you totally don't see it
coming even though that's the point of
the show it's the first episode that
starts with him having a stroke pretty
yeah you know yep yeah I agree
and uh man the way he died so realistic
yeah well they're just trying to pump
his naked body and just yeah yeah
so wild Kendall at the end
cold as [__]
cold as hell yeah but I was saying to
Elena I mean I think it's obvious but
I've always felt in the beginning that
Logan was trying to extract the devil
out of Kendall
yeah you know basically nagging him
being like you're a [__] yeah you're a
[__] trying to make him be like I'm not
a [__] like I always felt that Logan's
thing was whoever comes to cut my head
off is the one that deserves it yeah
and Kendall is the only one
who actually tried to kill him yeah
[Music]
yeah in every which way possible yeah
and now
whoa he's turning
turn turning bad
I love I love him like essentially
blackmailing this dude yeah also it's so
funny you see the twit the tweet it was
like it's just a photo of this dude and
they're like why does this guy have the
smallest snack in the world and why is
nobody talking yeah dude yeah
here we go oh yeah let's read the quote
let's get this quote
the negative case would go you're a
clumsy interloper so good you gotta buy
rope after that
you're a clumsy interloper and no one
trusts you the only guy pulling for you
is dead and now you're just married to
the ex-boss's daughter and she doesn't
even like you
what's the follow-up sentence there
isn't there a follow-up
I swear
oh yeah there you go and
and you are fair and squarely [__]
dance
fair and squarely [__] yeah
so good clumsy interloper is so so
perfect perfect someone called you that
whoever wrote that like hats off that's
like you've been around money yeah yeah
oh yeah
damn clumsy interloper clumsy interloper
how but it it just perfectly it like
aptly describes Tom specifically yeah
yeah he is he's weirdly like why does he
Bounce from side to side he has that
sort of like goofball clumsy
uh personality he's just weird even his
retelling of
Schiff remember when we first met yeah I
met you in France yeah and I kept
touching you and I kept asking do you
like this do you like
what the [__] get your [__]
interloper yeah yeah clumsy interloper
get out of here do you like to remember
when I interloped in France I flew to
you I interloped
imagine Tom eating your box dude
imagine him eating your truck [__] yeah
do you like this
is this good get away from my truck dude
yeah
this guy's this guy is just oh man
yeah Tom is a bozo gotta get him out of
there
so funny that he thought there was even
a chance yeah
come on Tom yeah get real
and this is why the plane was in the
poster yeah you can see the reflection
of the plane in the building of the
poster for this season and it was a
subtle hint sorry it's a hard pivot here
what is this ninja response to Falling
you haven't seen this no oh you're gonna
like this
well I'm not about the sunny V2
[Music]
[__] yeah
yeah
how else can I brutal fall off how else
can I piss you off today yeah
[Laughter]
straight sis
uh uh Catholic gun owning fallen off
twitch streamer how else can I piss you
off today no no dude
Catholic um
uh
um blue hair Louis Vuitton preferred
customer yes uh house owning PJ flying
PJ flying
ex-professional gamer yeah
how else can I piss you off today
what are those sunglasses those are
rough man are they dude or are they cool
like really look at this for a second
and ask yourself is this cool here's the
thing I I would out on the bike yeah if
I was you know on my you ever see that's
ninja laughing at you and I was out in
the mountains yeah I'd be rocking those
yeah this ninja laughing at you he's
like you still have to exercise
I just what's the [__] everyone's on now
oh yeah he's like I just take ozempic I
can afford it I take a Zen pic and Trend
and not even work out
damn
yeah his hair dude
do you think any of the blue is like
getting in his actual brain yeah like
when he diesel they cut open his head
and his brain is [__] blue it just
looks like Kool-Aid
like it looks like it's been soaking
yeah
just put a straw in there yeah yeah oh
it's sweet nice blueberry blouse
delicious damn what a crazy video can I
see it one more time
falling off
wait man they played from the beginning
[Music]
I agree
sick man it didn't even he looked like
nervous at the end too like it didn't
really look like he was that confident
in what is like his you know mic drop
moment yeah spy glasses so where is he
they have a camera on them
oh the Spy brand
foreign
Cody was just really interested for a
second those cameras now I'm just
wondering okay scroll up again look at
the hole in the middle and they're
called spot you said they're spy glasses
I was like why would you be they
actually might have a camera in them no
they very well could they very well
could it's just it's super funny
look at a camera
also if they were spy glasses is like
the least yeah like subtle thing yeah
yeah just a [__] AR headset it's like
why are you wearing that inside oh no
reason
no reason at all people think about
falling off yeah
and I'm just picturing you buying
clothing from Spy you get a t-shirt
you're like there's a camera in this
somewhere
these pants have a camera in them yeah
there's five pants yeah it's pretty sick
dude spy was a sick brand when I was
like 14. it still is dude come on come
on look at that I'm not saying anything
about it now I'm just saying like back
in the day yeah I used to be like very
into spy yeah goggles right yeah they do
it all wait can we look at that tweet
and see where ninja was going
can we look at the ninja PJ tracker and
see where he went recently
this is cringe Ninja
you are not cringe Chandler
what
cringya cringya
I want to know where he was going same
go to go to Twitter maybe he posted a
pic here in Cologne I mean third house
his career has been pretty pretty wild
in terms of like how he's just been able
to still make money after his Peak yep
I mean that's just that's just brand
recognition dude
I guess but like
you know I kind of hate saying people
have fallen off or whatever but like I
don't know people talk about streamers
and the biggest streamers or whatever
he's never brought up anymore yes right
yes he's definitely not in the Zeitgeist
but he's still probably making
just as much money yeah yeah so like
that's what I mean for money
yeah
uh
I guess maybe he
was flying home from somewhere
he's selling crazy man wearing ninja
merch is wild yeah
that is so wild you're just literally
dressed up like a gaming mouse
crazy colors
[__]
hey you know I'm just jealous
I'm just jealous man so am I I wish I
had the fall off was a PJ
follow me off that's true actually